the other person we lost was dawn wells
from uh gilligan's island
i know yeah she uh died i think from
covid
yes complications they say of covid you
know the show was holding on for three
years it wasn't a big hit couldn't
believe that when i saw that in the
obituaries i was like it was only three
years
it became big in syndication we must
have watched all those episodes a
million
times right i remember watching
gilligan's island and all of a sudden
like someone would show up
for an episode and they'd get off the
island but the the crew
the crew right right right right
i remember one time somebody took a
submarine off the uh island
there was a russian cosmonaut land in
there and got on the island
right but whenever they got off they
never had room for everyone
else and they were supposed to be
sending back help right
exactly right and somehow the help never
really
really
came but yeah i was shocked that that
the show was only on for three seasons
because i watched it forever in
syndication
how did the globetrotters specifically
get off the island like what was their
move a helicopter actually i think it
was
and uh there was no room on the
helicopter and somehow
[Music]
yeah to get everybody else off the
island yet they still managed to play
basketball while they were on the island
somehow it was a bizarre
bizarre episode did gilligan set up a
hoop was that the whole thing
i think the professor the professor set
up the whole court and everything
and yet he couldn't figure out how to
fix a hole in a boat for years
marianne her backstory is she was from
kansas
and called into a radio station and won
the three-hour tour
but she was modeled after judy garland
in wizard of oz that was her
sort of look well what an unfortunate
thing she actually won a radio contest
and then got ended up stranded on an
island i mean three-hour tour
what is the considered the best
gilligan's island episode
and you're probably the one where they
had the talent show
and they all had to do different acts
and stuff and then for a few
like the monkey became part of the
regular cast
almost and gilligan would be messing
around the monkey with a monkey non-stop
but i think the talent show is probably
one of the better ones right i
remember yeah that monkey became like
gilligan's sidekick
yes yeah and uh but we always
debate how are the best you know theme
songs i do think gilligan's island is
one of the best
theme songs ever for a television show
tells the story perfectly you remember
it it's catchy
and uh they even changed the lyrics my
god
what a [ __ ] show well anyway
rest in peace uh don wells
you